كاتب وشاعر ومترجم من مدينه الشرقاط اي
اشور كات يعني مدينه الذئاب وهي احد اقضيه
محافظه صلاح الدين العراقيه حاصل على
شهاده الدكتوراه من جامعه مدريد وهو استاذ
للادب في اسبانيا كتب لعده لغات منها
العربيه والاسبانيه وترجمت اعماله كذلك
لعده لغات بين سطور ما يكتب ستجدونه يتحدث
عن رجل مهزوم وهارب وامراه قويه تصل
بقوتها حد الذئبه العاشقه لكن هي عاشقه
لمن لا احد يدري هو سيحدثنا عن ذلك ضيفي
في برنامج صباح العربيه اليوم الكاتب
العراقي محسن الرمزي الذي غاب عن العراق
منذ عام
1993 وعاد اليوم ضيفا في معرض بغداد
الدولي للكتاب
[موسيقى]
نورتني صباح العربيه بعد سنه واحده راح
يصير غيابك عن العراق 30 سنه بالضبط
انت متواصل مع جمهورك على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بشكل ممتاز شلون لقيت العوده
وشلون شفت الجمهور عن قرار
يؤذينا كتاب الذين نعيش في المنفى او في
المقترب هو جمهورنا
نفقد اولا المصدر الرئيسي لحكاياتنا
وقصصنا وموضوعنا الرئيسي نكتب عنه عن بعض
وهو الافضل انه تكون عايش في حراره
يعني شيء لا يصدق
نفس الحراره نفس الجمال تخيل عندي قريه
عمرها 73 سنه وعندي قارئه عمرها 13 سنه
في وما بينهم وانا اكثر شيء للشباب
[موسيقى]
والمسرح وما شاء الله بالروايه الى كتابات
كثيره فانت الى اي جنس ادبي تعتقد انك
تنتمي
والكاتب اداه اللغه مثل النجار
وطاوله كانوا نفس الشيء النهايه كاتب وين
تعددت الاجناس طبعا
بالتجربه والمعرفه نحتاج مساحه او سائل
التعبير والروايه قادر على استيعاب هذه
الافكار اكثر اكثر
باللغه الاسبانيه
لماذا لم تكتب باللغه العربيه بصراحه حلو
يعني العراق العراق
[موسيقى]
وانا في راي حسب تجربتي في العالم العراق
افضل بلد بالشعر كم من ونوعا عبر التاريخ
والى اليوم والان تربينا عن الشرفه كان
لديه هيبا يعني له هيبه عندي يعني ما اقدر
ادخل هكذا وفتجرات وانا اكتب يعني بس ما
قلت انشر سريا بالعربي لان كل العراق
شعراء كبار بس بالاسباني تجرات
[موسيقى]
الجزء الثاني وقال انها جزء ثاني من حدائق
الريس عاده الجزء الثاني يكون اضعف من
الكتب الجزء الاول فكيف حافظت على هذا
التميز خاصه انه القراء قالوا انه الروايه
جميله
[موسيقى]
الجزء الثاني ثالث لان دائما سوف يقارن
بالجزء الاول ودائما يطلع
وانا ترددت ولكن ناشر الانجليزي اصر انه
هذه لازم تكتب البرتغالي
فبصراحه الذي اعانني تقنيا محرر المحرر
الانجليزي كان يراجع اورايد هذه ليس
موجوده عندنا في ثقافتنا محررين
[موسيقى]
جمهورك المتابع لك من خلال صباح العربيه
لبرنامج صباح العربيه شنو القادم
اريد تحتوي لاننا دائما مفردات الوفاء
تؤثر به
لاهلي وفي لبلادي وفي على الصعيد الشخصي
فهذه وفاء للحكايات التي حكت لي امي وجدتي
واخواتي الكبيرات وحاول ان احاول الحكايات
الشعبيه يعني انا كاتبه وانا صغير الى
روايه
الان لازم اقول لازم يعني لا نغامر ولكن
هو راح يكون مبدئيا
خرافات سميناتي الجميلات
[موسيقى]